we're setting up the new machine here
I'll show off the setup in a
second but yeah I should be back doing
Dev here um finishing up the new
release working on everything there and
there should be some cool new stuff
going
on let's see if WSL is
easy all right that
seems decent in
enough
um yeah
Docker do we need drivers I wonder or do
you think that's out of the box
fine oh wait you need Docker desktop cuz
WSL
yeah I have some cool stuff to show off
in the meantime that I've been working
on
new website is a work in
progress you can just try all of our M
here in browser there's some glitches
and stuff still but um you know you can
try all these different M most of them
have neural Nets pre-trained like this
is a neural net playing you can hold
shift old shift and now I'm playing
it I can let go of shift and then the
neural net takes over that all works
nicely have a whole collection of
environments here
nice new docss these commands have not
been tested yet I will have to fix these
but uh you know this is first pass on
all the new
docs and then I've also ported over most
of the blog uh as
well including some new
stuff it's also a product page for
companies so
uh really the only thing that needs to
be done now is just a bunch of cleanup a
bunch of fixing of
policies and a bunch of like pre-launch
stuff basically it's in a very good spot
though and then we're just going to have
to see how much polish we want to add in
and then that'll be
launch so I've kind of just been doing a
bunch of this work on my own on my
laptop for the last couple of
weeks um but now I think most of it'll
be back to being streamed most of
it schedule will be a little bit
different because I'm in Florida now and
I have to somewhat plan around the
weather
so it'll likely be a morning stream and
then an evening
stream today I would have been here
earlier except I had to set up the
desktop
uh probably this afternoon once I clean
stuff up a bit I will show the setup and
everything this is by far the nicest
just Hardware set up